foreign
[Music]
hello and welcome to I'd like to know my
name is CA Murray and after a bit of an
absence it is my privilege and pleasure
to be back with my pastor my mentor my
friend Pastor Stephen Bohr president and
founder of this ministry pastor always
good to work with you good to be back in
the chair with you you have no idea how
much we missed you
um CA is a real blessing to our ministry
and when he's not around it's not the
same oh praise the Lord
as you can see the rumors are true yes
we do like each other here at Secrets
unsealed we enjoy each other's company
we socialize together outside of
ministry and we have a good time in the
Lord amen this program is one of our
favorites because it gives us a chance
to study the word of God but also to
know those things that are on your heart
the questions that you may have
concerning your faith your faith walk
from the Bible
we like to get the questions we like to
answer the questions and we have a good
time in doing so we make you this
promise as we always do that if an
answer can be found from the word of God
we will find that answer and give you
only what the word of God has to say we
are rather late in the history of this
world in fact too late to be bantering
about men's opinions we want to know the
word of the Lord and we want to get a
word from the Lord so we promise to give
you that word from the Lord if indeed it
can be found
should you like to get in on the fun we
encourage you to do so you can write us
at TV at some
tv.org that is TV at
suntv.org as you can well imagine the
list of questions is rather long so if
you don't hear your question in the
first week or two after you send it in
we're going to get to it we promise you
we will get to it we don't like to rush
through questions our our our goal is
not speed our goal is accuracy from the
word of God so we may get to one
question uh two three questions per
program it all depends on the question
so we'll get to it we promise you but um
uh hold fast we are coming and we will
get to your question Pastor if you would
ask the Lord to be with us we'll launch
out in today's program let's pray Father
in heaven we come before your awesome
throne
and we do so reverently and humbly
through the merits and the power of
Christ we ask that you will be with us
as we do our best to answer these
questions we ask that it will be a
blessing for those who are watching this
program and we just ask that you will
give us your wisdom as we work today we
pray in Jesus name amen amen Ambassador
just before we go into this program and
I know this question is something that
you have dealt with and I've heard you
speak on this subject uh so I know
you're a well-versed on it but last week
on the program there was a question that
came in from a person who who titles his
uh email who is that guy it was a nine
part question and we really didn't have
time to to work our way through all nine
Parts it was quite long it had to do
with the the origins of the Bible the
canonization of the Bible uh basically
where did we get the Bible from how did
it come through in this form what is
apocryphal what is pseudopigraphy what
is Canon uh uh and so we didn't it would
just take so long but this person really
needs is to do a short study on the
history of the Bible I know there's a
great book called how we got the Bible
it's in my library don't remember who
wrote it but perhaps the person doesn't
look it up maybe you know of of some
books that may give him some some
information on that also but we weren't
able to take tackle such a big question
you know in the time that was a lot of
to us
I of course was not able to be here for
that program
there are some things though however
that I think that we could address
concerning the several questions that
this individual asked I think it's nine
questions yeah there were nine uh how
much did you cover of the questions that
he asked we did we didn't actually we
did three questions last week and since
this we had like a minute left and there
was so much here we didn't cover it at
all okay can we maybe just uh say a few
things about uh the canonization
um I just want to say that uh the the
canonization of scripture is not
something that happened in a point of
time precisely it actually was a process
a process of centuries uh regarding the
Old Testament the Old Testament uh Canon
was pretty much settled by the Council
of jamnia in 135 A.D
but even before that uh you know the
Canon of the Old Testament was pretty
much settled there's not a lot of
dispute about the Canon of the Old
Testament yes there you know the last
three books that were to be included in
the Canon of course were the Book of
Esther uh mainly because the name of God
is not mentioned there correct uh the
word Song of Songs because it sounded a
little bit too romantic to be in the
Bible to use a mild term and the Book of
Ecclesiastes because it was so
pessimistic yeah vanity of vanities
everything is Vanity so those are the
last books to be included uh but the the
Canon was pretty much settled in the
times of Christ yes uh you know Jesus
referred to the two parts three person
portions of the Old Testament uh when he
talked to the two disciples on the road
to Emmaus he says beginning in the uh
the you know beginning with Moses yes
that's the five books of Moses and all
the prophets all the prophets correct he
expounded to them in all the scriptures
the things concerning himself so that's
the Torah the nebiim and the quesubim so
there was three Parts yes to the Canon
uh in the days of Christ in the Old
Testament Canon now with regards to the
New Testament Canon it was pretty much
settled
in Apostolic times yes you know there
was some discussion in the period of the
church fathers you know origen who was
known for being very original yeah had
some questions about some of the 27
books in the Canon but um but really uh
the New Testament Cadman was pretty much
settled uh in Apostolic times yes an
early post-apostolic times so there's
not a lot of dispute about which books
should be in the New Testament yes uh
regarding Luther
there were certain books that Luther did
not like I had issues with yes no what
what people don't realize is that uh
Luther
translated those books that he didn't
particularly care for
um in the in the Bible that he published
in 1522 you put them at the end of the
New Testament and those books were the
book of Hebrews
uh I suppose it's because he didn't
really understand the sanctuary service
the book is tremendously christ-centered
oh very much I mean but but probably he
did really wasn't into studying the
sanctuary
um I don't know exactly the reason why
he did not like Hebrews uh he had issues
with James well we know that we know why
yeah because because Luther was
struggling against the idea that man
could work his way to heaven precisely
that was his name and so and so James
speaks a lot about Works in fact chapter
2 says that Abraham was justified not
only by faith but where he works yes and
Rahab also and so Luther that just
wouldn't fit but we need to understand
Luther within the context of what he was
fighting against precisely where he came
from he was living today he would
probably have a different view of James
uh he also did not like Revelation
because all he could see in there was
beasts and mysterious numbers and things
like that so he could not really find
Christ in the Book of Revelation I
believe that today he would look at it
differently yes and then he also had
issues with the book of uh with the book
of Jude uh it's kind of a little strange
book in the New Testament uh but the
main thing is that to determine whether
a book belonged to the Canon was that
all of the books would be in harmony
there would be no contradiction between
what one book says in another book says
precisely and it was Guided by God you
know divinely Guided by God which books
should be in the Old Testament which
book should be in the New Testament I
think a point is very well taken we have
to allow God the ability uh
realizability to to take care of his own
books
um if they did not have a certain flavor
now if you if you if you read the
Apocrypha you begin to run into
something that just don't sound like the
rest of the Bible yeah uh
don't want to go into all of that but it
just doesn't sound like that I think
your point for about Luther is well
taken given where he was coming from
given what he was trying to free himself
from given the the the life he lived
anything that's smacked of or even
smelled of Works he was going to reject
right
um Hebrews are sort of is it puts Christ
at the Pinnacle of everything
um and for some reason he didn't work
his way through all of that uh you had
things going on in the Old Testament
about Christ is the summation the
Pinnacle of all of that he didn't see
that and of course Revelation Christ is
not sitting on the surface you got to
dig a little bit right to find Christ he
is there he is Thoroughly there but he's
not lying on the ground to pick up you
gotta you gotta scrape a little bit to
get down to him right and and Luther
wasn't you know Luther was not the
be-all and end-all of the Protestant
Reformation he was a shining star he was
a great light he was a a very strong
reformer but it didn't stop with Lucy
there were other individuals who brought
their own particular uh
flavor to it and added to it also so it
doesn't stop with Loser Luther was just
a very important part like Martin Luther
King in the in the Civil Rights Movement
it wasn't all Martin Luther King he was
a shining light but there were others
who added to it all right and you know
when you look at the Apocrypha the
Apocrypha had their origin mainly in the
inter-testamental period correct long
after the Old Testament uh period ended
you know the Book of Malachi is about
425 BC which is still within the
parameters of the Old Testament before
the inter-testamental period correct but
in the inter-testamental period you have
wild books yeah uh you know that that
contradict many of the things that are
in the Bible one example is uh you know
the the author of The Books of Maccabees
yes you know he says in his book you
know I've written to the best of my
recollection I'm paraphrasing if anybody
can find anything that's not
particularly accurate let me know you
know well that doesn't particularly
sound like the inspired scripture No and
and there's other things in the
Apocrypha that clearly show that these
books should not be included in the
Canon because they contradict some
things that are already in the accepted
case I think the the one thing that that
we should leave with this this uh this
writer is the fact that it wasn't a
bunch of people went in a room and came
out and said this is a candidate right
you know it happened over a period of
time we believe as Guided by the holy
spirit of God and it was settled over a
period of Time Books containing the same
information having the same flavor uh
agreeing with each other as opposed to
some people went into a room closed the
door and came out and said here it is
yeah we received a vision these are the
books that belong to the Bible it was a
process they were very meticulous and
very careful you know in order to do
things right you have to do them slowly
correct but surely correct uh so you
know there's so many questions in this
uh one question yes that it's difficult
to address them all but um I hope that
this person you know you don't really
have to we don't have to give a
recommendation here as far as books are
concerned the person can Google and you
know how did we get the Bible and find
an abundance of information as to books
that are available and articles that
have been been written so on you know
the uh Google makes it very easy to do
research these days yeah it makes
anybody a genius
we want to move into this question
because I know this is something that
you've given study on and we've talked
about this before uh in the beginning
God created the heavens and the Earth
this is uh Lewis that I'm I'm reading
this question from Andy yourself was
without form and void and darkness was
upon the face of the deep and the spirit
of God moved upon the face of the waters
question I'd like to know when and why
the Earth was was without form and void
was it after creation or before and
where did the waters come from in verse
two was it from creation by God well of
course this this is
um a question about about the beginnings
was that after creation or before well
it was at creation and that's when the
Bible picks up the the story
um
um when and why
um was the earth without form and void
so maybe you want to launch into that
yeah the big question is how long was
this planet here
before creation week I think that might
be the gist of this question
and there are two views
one view is that it was very possible
that this planet was here
for a long period of time before
creation week the other idea is that the
planet itself was created
as God was about to begin creation week
I personally think on the basis of the
fourth Commandment that uh this Earth
was made and then immediately God began
began creation week and the reason for
that uh is the fourth Commandment
the fourth Commandment of God's law uh
Genesis I mean Exodus chapter 20 and
verse 8 and before we read that text we
need to read Genesis 1 1 and 2 again
okay it says there in Genesis 1 1 and 2
in the beginning God created
the heavens and the Earth okay
and it says the Earth was without form
and void and darkness was on the face of
the deep and the spirit of God was
hovering over the face of the waters
so in the beginning God created the
heavens and the Earth
and it continues saying the Earth was
without form and void now did God create
the heavens and the Earth within the
parameters of the of the seven days of
creation the fourth Commandment seems to
indicate so yes because it says there in
Exodus chapter 20 and uh let's read
verse 11. it says for in six days the
Lord made the heavens and the Earth
so was the creation of the heavens and
the Earth within the parameters of the
six days yes yes it says in six days God
made the heavens and the Earth so the
idea that I think that the Bible shares
is that
um God
on the first day of the week created the
planet and then immediately he began uh
by by making the light or creating the
light so but there are others who
believe that this planet was here
probably for millions of years before
creation week and you know even though
there are people who object to what I'm
going to say I don't see that there's an
issue let's suppose that the planet was
here for 10 million years before
creation week but it had no life it was
without form and void I mean that
doesn't make any difference the
difference is that we believe that
creation week took place about six
thousand years ago right and that God
made everything during that period of
seven days yeah whether the planet was
here long before that yeah as a planet
you know it's like all the stars they've
been there who knows how long yeah
um so you know let me let me just give
an illustration of uh you know how this
works let's suppose that you know Mars
is a desolate Planet let's just suppose
that Mars has been there for 10 million
years
and suddenly God says you know what I
think that we're going to uh in seven
days we're going to fix up Mars yeah so
it can sustain life
would we have a problem with that no no
problem at all that it was there 10
million years the issue is whether
whether creation weak yes took place in
recent times that's that's the key and
sometimes this this this idea of of an
earth undeveloped sitting around 10
million years is is an attempt to
harmonize it with what they see as
science it gives you those those long
years but and I think your point is well
taken that's not the key that's not the
Crux of the issue the issue is did God
create the world as we know it in six
literal days that's the key and once you
settle that there's there's no argument
there's no dissonance it it flows nicely
and a short chronology precisely in
other words there are you know theistic
evolutionists and uh you know those who
believe in Progressive creation that say
well you know uh creation it took place
maybe millions of years ago yes
we cannot believe that because it goes
against the idea in Genesis that
creation was done in seven days it
actually is an attack on an indirect
attack on the Sabbath it is it is it is
because if you if you pull out those six
literal days you cannot have a Sabbath
correct because the Sabbath is a literal
day right so um it's it's one or the
other
well said pastor well done
all right
um this is from Shogun
and um this deals with let me just read
the question I'm a firm believer and
will never change that I do want to know
what uh Stephen Bohr has to say about
the about how Gilgamesh not sure the
spelling and the Bible have some things
in common and since Gilgamesh was much
earlier how this relates thank you
well uh you know she's talking about the
Epic of Gilgamesh which is a flood story
a Babylonian flood story not from not
Babylon from Nebuchadnezzar's time but
very early Babylon power Babel Babylon
uh well you know there's three
possibilities
one possibility is that the Bible
borrowed from Gilgamesh
and that's what uh many scholars who do
not believe in the inspiration of the
Bible would say others say that
Gilgamesh borrowed from the Bible Well
you know there's too many discrepancies
that's not going to work the Bible is
later yes so the answer is very simple
they both draw
from an original source
and the reason why they're different is
because in the process of time stories
get bent out of shape for a second so
that's why the Epic of Gilgamesh you
know it has many similarities to the
biblical story because it's going back
to the original event there was a flood
and the story was passed on but as the
story has passed on it's embellished
they add to it they change it the
takeaway but the source that we can
trust is the Bible story of The Source
because it's not Sensational you know
it's not Sensational like uh like the
story of Epic of Gilgamesh that the gods
sent the flood because they couldn't
sleep because the people on Earth were
making too much noise you know this
ridiculous ideas
you know that is part of what um Garrett
Cornelius burkhar calls the ontological
argument for the existence of God he
says in all cultures in the world there
there are usually three figures there is
a creative figure a destroyer figure
which we call a devil and a redeemer
figure and all all cultures have that
they've they've sort of Twisted it in
Mali and then and and and sort of turned
it around but all cultures have it so it
it there must be a common source from
which all of those cultures borrowed so
that is an argument for a it's a
rational argument for the existence of
God in other words if you don't have a
Bible you can still
prove the existence of God by looking at
the fact that everybody's got a god
conscious all cultures have it they give
it different names they arrive at it by
different Roots but they all have it so
there must have been a common reality
somewhere in history and Gilgamesh tends
to fall into that almost all cultures
have a flood story or a flood-ish story
uh so this again proves that there was a
common source and that of course is is
God the father
so it does work it's one of the
arguments in favor of a global flood
precisely because because the stories
that are held by many different cultures
are all over the world I mean if it was
a local flood you would expect maybe if
it was in India you would have an Indian
story about the flood but the flood
stories and all these ancient cultures
are actually all over the world
precisely and so that is a strong
argument that there was an original
event yes yes yes very good
um good question and uh hopefully we
have dealt with it fairly
um Jamie Martin Martinez is our next
question have a couple of people uh um I
have a question
can people make it in the final judgment
while they are still drinking coffee and
struggling to overcome coffee
at that moment if we have not overcome
it uh will that sin keep us from
entering please help me with this
question uh I'm struggling with this now
before I turn it over to you I this is
what I want to say
the issue is not coffee
is a symptom of a larger issue to my
mind the issue is obedience
to the will and way of God known light
precisely
you for him it's coffee
for someone else it may be something
else but the issue is are we going to
obey God
um are we going to uh uh follow his
directives and Disobedience to any one
of those directives can keep you out of
the Kingdom so coffee is just a symptom
of a larger problem the problem is not
coffee uh you're it his issue is coffee
but there's a bigger problem uh at foot
of course it all depends on whether the
person is justifying the drinking of
coffee or whether the person is really
sincerely sorry that they have this
habit and they are struggling and
longing for the God for God to deliver
them yes from the consumption of coffee
or whatever it is you know I have the
story of my grandfather
um my dad's dad he had a terrible
problem with smoking and you know he
came to an Evangelistic Crusade drunk
I'm not going to tell the whole story
and you know he came to the Lord he
accepted the evidence message became a
deacon in the church praise God and um
you know he had this this issue with
smoking he smoked a lot and in the
morning as the day began he would take
his cigarette pack and he would say I
hate this I hate this habit and there
was a cornfield next to the uh next to
the house where they lived he would take
the pack of cigarettes and he was heave
it as hard as he could into the rows of
corn corn yeah guess what he was doing
just a short while later he was on his
hands and knees looking for the back of
cigarettes but praise the Lord he had
the right attitude he wasn't justifying
smoking yes but he was struggling he
wanted to leave the habit of smoking
because he knew it was against the
Lord's will and the Lord eventually gave
him the victory praise God so it the
question is are you justifying the
drinking of coffee or are you struggling
with coffee or whatever other besetment
you have I think that's a real issue
yeah yeah I got a similar story in my
very first church uh my my head Deacon
was a smoker and somebody came past your
Deacon's a smoker uh so I went to his
house and and talked to him he said yeah
I have a half and he really wanted to
give it up uh he'd throw the pack away
and leave a couple in the drawer you
know that kind of
that kind of thing but he he eventually
got got the victory it wasn't easy he
had to struggle with it uh and he
struggled with it for years but he did
get the victory so two things come to
mind one God is able to free us from
whatever problem we amen fall into or or
walk into and and and because you fail
one time don't give up righteous man
falls seven times get backs up and keeps
on walking so so even if you have
um Fallen I like first John 1 7. uh if
we walk in the light as he is in the
light we have fellowship and the blood
of Christ cleanses us you know uh uh uh
from sin so
keep walking
step by step as I said in Spanish poco
poco little by little let's keep on
walking and the Lord will give you the
victory you know the Bible does not say
I can do most things through Christ who
strengthens me well said I can do some
things through Christ who strengthens me
it says I can do all things through
Christ who strengthens me uh you know
some people say well the human you know
our human sinful nature is just so
powerful that there are certain things
that we can't give up what they're
really saying is that God is Not Strong
we're not saying man is weak they're
saying God isn't strong enough to give
you the victory if you commit your ways
to him yes yes you know I was talking
with my doctor the other day
um and and one of the things we're
talking about is medicine today is is is
is
constructed it's it's not really
designed to get you to change it's
designed to medicate you while you keep
on doing what you're doing you know if
you if you're eating a lot of meat and
you've got high cholesterol and you're
you're a thing is bad well we give you a
pill to just don't stop eating meat just
take this pill uh kind of thing so the
idea of Victory is not really part of
medicine anymore more but the idea of
Victory is Central to the Walk of the
Christian you know I had an uncle who
passed away a while back and he was
talking to my mom one day and he said
you know in all the years I've been
practicing Psychiatry I haven't healed a
single person and my wife and my mom
says to him well why why you what what
do people want he says well you know
people want me to help them feel better
and continue living the way they are
precisely well time is about up folks so
thank you for your questions we
appreciate them God bless and we hope to
see you next time in our program I'd
like to know
thank you
[Music]